CVPR forbids tweeting about papers, AI is
used to restore Rembrandt, and potential
deep fake has big consequences in the country of
Myanmar. Welcome to this week's ML news. Hello,
and welcome to ML news, you're absolutely regular
every week on Monday update on what's going on
in the machine learning world. The first one,
fresh of the press, Walter Scheirer writes the
result of the CVPR 2021 PAMI-TC votes are in, all
four motions passed. This decides over the future
of the CVPR conference in the next few years.
Now you can see the motions here and particularly
interesting is motion number four social media
limitation during review, overwhelmingly accepted.
This motion was proposed by Michael Black and says
social media promotion of papers is prohibited
during the review period for CVPR, except for
automatic posting of new preprints by archives. So
essentially means during the review period, you're
not allowed to go and tweet about your papers,
you're only allowed to upload them to archive and
there is an exception, because archives sometimes
automatically tweets new papers, anything else, no
go. Now there is a bit of an outrage about this,
I have to say it's not as big of a rule change as
it seems. So the reasoning behind this is there
already used to be a press release ban during
the review period. And this motion simply extends
the press release ban to social media, because
effectively while you couldn't do a press release,
you could still tweet about your papers and get
the word out this way. The big concern here is
that groups with a lot of following or a lot of
press influence will have their papers exposed to
more people, which could bias the review process.
Now in the light of already existing press ban,
extending the ban to social media makes sense.
However, I feel the bigger issue is why is there
a press ban at all? Why aren't you allowed to
talk about your papers as they are under review.
So the argumentation of the proposal is that this
can bias the reviewers judgment if they're exposed
to this work. Now, as much as I like the idea of
peer review, it's really not working currently,
they say peer review is the backbone of science,
the process helps detect mistakes or false claims
before the work appears in public. Yeah, right.
When has this happened the last time I've exposed
more false claims on my channel than the entire
CVPR conference in the review process, we have
to get away from this notion that peer review is
adequately constituted by three dudes sitting on
the toilet while it's flicking through your paper
on their smartphone and then giving a weak reject,
I argue that social media is the actual peer
review. What seems weird to me is that they have
sort of an FAQ here answering some of the worries
about this. So there are questions, Why won't
this slow down scientific progress? and, what
about archive? And their claim here is that no,
this won't slow down scientific progress because
experts in the field make scientific progress,
not the general public. And here again, archive
tweets are largely followed by experts in the
field and not the general public. Wait, I thought
the peer review was supposed to be experts.
Aren't the peer reviewers exactly the people
who would follow the archive publications like
if it was just the general public receiving the
social media posts? Why are we worried, after all,
experts make the contributions in the scientific
field not the general public. The truth is that
currently social media imperfect, unbalanced, with
different followings as it is constitutes a much
more rigorous peer review process than what we
have at conferences, the social network that we've
built up online effectively highlights interesting
papers. And yes, a lot of them come from big
companies. But let's face it, they have really
good researchers and a lot of resources. But
often it happens enough that some no name paper
gets surfaced because it is interesting. Whereas
in the conference proceedings, it would just get
lost. This is in the light of other conferences,
doing things like archive blackouts before
submitting, and people calling for entirely
banning archive uploads before conferences,
all of this is highly suspicious. Now who is
really profiting from the current system and who's
really going to lose from a more open approach to
publishing, it's going to be people that take part
in the nice little collusion rings that we have.
These are people publishing dozens and dozens
and dozens of paper each year in some niche field
where everyone knows everyone and everyone knows
who everyone's paper is from and they just kind
of accept each other. However, when the public
encounters these papers, they're generally boring,
not interesting and don't actually contribute
anything to the knowledge of humankind. So yeah,
if research is more in public, that's not
going to fly anymore, which is a good thing.
So future CVPR submitters, all to youtubers
inboxes are at your disposal. Enough of us
are bribable so you still have good outlets If you
have money. Well, won't that tilt the balance even
more into the direction of big corporations. So in
conclusions, conferences are a hell bent on making
themselves not important even faster than they
already are. Next news, supermarket news writes
Walmart and lists artificial intelligence for
online grocery substitution. So this is actually
pretty interesting in that Walmart has people
going around shopping for you. So you place an
online order, and these people go and they buy
stuff for you. However, sometimes items are out
of stock. And when that happens, a substitution
needs to happen. So Walmart apparently has built
some sort of a recommender system that tells
these shoppers which product they can substitute.
I originally thought this was a pretty simple
problem, like, Oh, we don't have this milk have
this other milk, but it seems to be that it's not
that easy. And they claimed since deploying the AI
solution, customer acceptance of online
grocery substitutions has climbed over 95%.
So good for them real world problem AI solves it,
all good. Is this a marketing piece? Absolutely,
but still kinda cool. Okay, Nvidia releases alias
free again. And this fixes the supposed problem
of the strong dependence of GANs on the exact
coordinates of the pixels. Now, I won't go through
the paper here. But you should look at these
visualizations. They're pretty, pretty cool.
On the left, you see the old style GAN, and it's
so freaky look at the hair, it kind of stays in
place while the face goes around. Of course, there
are method fixes this particular problem. Here's
the same, it just kind of looks like a head that's
kind of sliding under a foreground layer of hair.
What's also praised about the new model is the
sort of better interpolations that you can see
right here. And again, you can see the less
dependence on the actual pixel coordinates,
particularly impressive I find to be this beach
interpolation, where you can see style GAN just
kind of keeps everything at the same place, esh,
while as the alias free gun tends to move around
a lot. Now whether these are cherry picked or
not, and whether in the final analysis, the alias
free GAN is really better than the style GAN, who
knows. Safe to say when it comes to GANs, we are
pushing the limits of what's doable, and we are
really getting into the territories of fine tuning
these things, hard to believe that like five
years ago, we could barely make a face. NO! YES!
Speaking of GANs, apparently in the country of
Myanmar, there is a confession video going around
of a politician confessing to transferring some
money, and due to artifacts in the video, people
claim it's a deep fake. Now this article here
explores this claim and comes to the conclusion
that probably the artifacts are more a compression
artifact because the video is very low quality,
but it does raise important questions as if we
had better and better and better at producing
realistic looking images, sound, and video, in
the future will have to develop new expectations
of what counts as real evidence of something
happening. A video of you saying something or
doing something might no longer be enough as you
could just always play that is a deep thing. Now
I wouldn't be so overly worried about this because
we have the same situation right now with writing.
If I simply claim to that a certain person who
recently passed away and once founded an antivirus
company has sent me an email briefly before his
death and the email said certain things, I could
even present you the email on a sheet of paper yet
you wouldn't necessarily believe me. So what we'll
have to change is just our expectations of which
mediums are valid forms of evidence and not easily
tampered with. I don't know what's going to be the
solution in the future, but I'm sure we'll come up
with something. Smithsonian magazine writes lost
edges of Rembrandt's nightwatch are restored using
artificial intelligence. Apparently this painting
had been cut at some point to hang it on some wall
and the cuts have been lost. Now artificial
intelligence has been used to restore this
painting, how nice. So apparently, this is a
multimillion dollar restoration project. And
at the same time, it seems like a really really
concerted effort, but also from what they tell
it It also seems like you could do it in five
minutes. On one hand, the input data seems to
be really rich. So there is x ray scanners, 528
digital exposures and so on. On the other hand,
they write things like though many museums
employ painters to reconstruct Masterworks,
the senior scientist Robert Erdmann was able to
use a computer to recreate the missing panels,
computer. So they apparently they use this new
technology called convolutional neural networks,
a type of artificial intelligence algorithm that
helps computers figure out what images may have
once looked like. Okay, the crux of the thing
now comes when they say apparently there is a
copy of the original painting that sort of shows
what it should lookalike. So essentially what
these researchers that appears to be something
like a sophisticated style transfer where they
use the copy of the image as the base, and then
transfer the style of Rembrandt on top of it.
Now this is both pretty cool in that we now have
technology that can do these things. But we also
have to be honest about what this is, this is
a believable way this could have looked like,
there is no way of knowing if Rembrandt actually
drew this particular thing or something else that
resulted in the same copy of this other painter.
In any case, the picture is now complete, thanks
to computer, thanks computer. Okay, Greenville
business magazine writes, Prisma health announces
artificial intelligence partnership to make
doctors more efficient to inform them with
their decisions and so on. And at the same time,
the Verge writes, a hospital algorithm designed to
predict a deadly condition misses most cases, and
it also had many false alarms. So the algorithm
was tasked with detecting sepsis, a complicated
condition that can bring patients into critical
state. Now the way this was trained was with data
labeled not whether the patient has sepsis or not,
but whether the doctor would submit a bill
for treatment of sepsis. So essentially,
it's trying to replicate what the doctors do and
not actually predict the patient's state, I get
that this is easier labels than actually figuring
out what happened. But also don't be surprised
if then it doesn't work better than the doctors.
They say it's essentially trying to predict what
physicians are already doing. Suffice to say,
while AI is a powerful tool that can definitely
help with many things, we still have to be careful
when we deploy it in the real world and actually
measure its performance. And given that this
article exists, performance has been measured,
and we're gonna go back to the drawing
board. Chip Huyen and others release a book
called introduction to machine learning
interviews. The book is mostly for interviewees,
but also for interviewers to prepare for machine
learning interviews, so if you have an interview
soon or if you're looking to interview
someone, this might be a nice resource
for you. The book is free and available,
give it a try, it might just get you a job.
As fast as one can go. Turn sketches into
stunning landscapes with Nvidia Canvas
written by Nvidia. So Nvidia has released
this new application called Canvas in which
you're able to sort of draw a doodle and it will
transform it into really nice looking pictures.
This is part of the Nvidia sort of artists suite
that helps people be more creative, I guess,
or less, or differently. I'm not sure how to
characterize this. The Canvas app is available
as a beta you can download it if you do have an
Nvidia graphics card I believe. I haven't tried
it out myself because all the graphics card I have
access to don't actually have a monitor on them.
So what do I do? Speaking of GPUs, good news
for deep learners as the register writes,
now that China has all bought banned
cryptocurrencies, GPU prices are falling
like Bitcoin. So China hasn't fully banned
cryptocurrencies, but is cracking down majorly
on them. And that means that some of the mining
power is going away. And with it, the GPU demand
is lower than it used to be. So if you wanted to
buy yourself a data center, now might be the time.
Facebook is looking to make your shopping
experience easier using AI, there have a
selection of software called product match that
helps identify products from pictures, among
other things. So this allows sellers to tag their
products easily, but it also allows you to find
products that you see somewhere or on someone.
So artificial intelligence might help you with
shopping in the future. And I can't wait to see
all the adversarial attacks on these systems. Yes,
for sure. I'm gonna sell you a Rolex. It's right
here. The AI system even says it's one, 3000
bucks, thank you. Google AI releases deeplab2 for
TensorFlow, which is a library to do pixel based
segmentation, or any sort of pixel based labeling
tasks. So this is on GitHub, you can go check
it out if you are in that space. it seems like
it's a good code base if you're in the research
directions or task of pixel based labeling, such
as semantic segmentation or texture labeling, or
explainable AI, give it a look. All right. Besides
all the news, I feel we should also cover some non
news. So I've seen this paper DeExperts decoding
time, control text generation with experts and
anti experts. Now this seems to be a good paper
as far as I can tell, it takes on the tasks of
mitigating toxicity in language generation. So as
you can see right here, you have some sort of base
language model that has some output and You have
what they call the experts and some of them are
non toxic and some of them are deliberately toxic.
And by contrasting non toxic experts and toxic
experts, you can then make sure that you reweighed
the outputs towards a non toxic behavior. Now,
I got nothing against this paper However, what
I want to say is that this is like a 100% recipe
of making a super toxic language model, all I have
to do is flip this one sign right here, I can just
take whatever this is I can flip one bit in the
algorithm and I make the most toxic language model
ever. To the big credits of the authors, this is
even acknowledged in the broader impact statement
they say we acknowledge that any controllable
detoxification method runs the risk of dual
use specifically this technology could be used to
automatically generate hateful text, for a broader
discussion of such risks and the risks of large
pre trained language models in general, please
see this stochastic carrots paper. Now there are
enough people that with every face up sampling
method cry that we shouldn't develop these
things, and all of this is dangerous, it should
be measured by the harm it causes and so on. And
here I have a method that flipping one single bit
will make it super duper toxic and harmful. Is
there anyone complaining about this paper? No,
zero. Where are these people. Are you really
telling me that a little paragraph in the
broader impact statement is gonna not cause the
harm, now I think I know how this works, because
we gave the proper citation, we have the proper
friends, we frame it in the proper way, and the
narrative uphold. So in my personal opinion, we
should not give too much power to these ethics
people. Unless papers like this one are met with
at least as much scrutiny as the papers they're
usually criticizing. Again, I'm totally fine
with this paper, then again, I'm also totally
fine with pretty much all the other papers,
I'm just calling for a bit of consistency here.
Okay, last news a Adilin Beatrice in analytics
inside writes, yes, artificial intelligence
can't do these things. It's an article about
what artificial intelligence isn't able to do,
and also a bit of an argument of why it won't
be able to do it in the near future. Among these
things is the classic use common sense to make
decisions argument and I love the example that
they give right here. For example, if we say, a
woman went shopping, she bought a beautiful dress,
she left the place with a big smile. If asked
what the woman shop a human would instantly say,
a beautiful dress, but answering the simple
questions is very difficult for artificial
intelligence. Alright, hold on. Here's GPT-J of
EleutherAI, a woman went shopping she bought a
beautiful dress, She left the place with a big
smile. Now she wants to return her purchase of,
and the model says the dress, she wants her
money back, totally lacking common sense. I get
it. It's just one example. But I think there are
much more effective ways to criticize artificial
intelligence than it doesn't have common
sense. Like if common sense is sort of your
intuitive gut feeling of things like it as common
sense. All right, this was it for this week's ML
news. How did you do today? Did you win? Did you
lose? Did you even know there was a game involved?
Who knows? We'll be here next week, at Monday,
nine o'clock. No questions asked. Take care.